2023 has been a wild Year my bank
collapsed Elon bought Twitter almost all
my friends got laid off all my favorite
crypto Bros are going to jail Tesla
successfully made it the DeLorean with a
Pontiac Aztec bringing us the Cyber
truck and chat GPT made me obsolete but
all this good news pales in comparison
to the changes web developers have seen
in JavaScript land over the last year
where almost every framework decided to
reinvent itself in 2023 in today's video
we'll look at 10 recent changes to
JavaScript that you may have missed
every year new language features get
standardized in ecmascript at which
point they're implemented in browsers
one of my favorite new features this
year is object Group by imagine you have
an array of objects where the objects
share a similar schema these might be
records from a database where every
object has a field of age you can use
groupy to separate the children from the
adults by defining a function that
groups anyone under 21 into children and
anyone over that into adults the end
result is an object organized into
groups that's a nice little utility but
one I find myself using even more often
is array two sorted along with two
splice and two reversed JavaScript
already had methods for sort and
reversed but the problem is that they
mutate the original array in place and
that's confusing because other methods
like map and filter don't do that
instead they copy the array and return a
new one with these methods you can now
sort reverse and splice an array by
treating the original as an immutable
value which tends to be the more sane
way to write your code web developers
also got some cool updates in the form
of brand new HTML elements like the
search tag is a more semantic way to
define a search box on a website which
can replace the more generic form tag
that's nice but the dialogue element is
way more powerful which allows you to
create actual modal dialogues and then
control them with JavaScript using
built-in methods like show modal and
close another nice utility but that
brings us to index 3 after years of
begging and pleading with Apple iOS
finally allows push notifications to
come from web apps and that's a huge win
for the
0.00001% of website users who actually
allow websites to send them push
notifications which is most likely your
grandpa who accidentally clicked the
allow button and now has no idea how how
to turn it off but now it's time to talk
about the fun stuff Frameworks the
world's most popular JavaScript
framework nextjs is an entirely
different framework than it was last
year thanks to the app directory which
became stable in May with version 13.4
the most notable difference is that you
can now fetch data directly inside react
components thanks to server components
which are react components that can run
on the server the reception to the app
directory has been somewhat mixed on one
hand it has a lot of awesome new
features and can simplify your code but
many have complained about it feeling
rushed and Half Baked kind of like the
way they launch video games nowadays
where they just get something out the
door then patch it up over the next few
years people have complained about
having to use the used client directive
everywhere due to Breaking existing
react libraries people have complained
about the slow Dev server which is
powered by rust which is weird because
anything powered by rust is supposed to
be fast and people have compared its new
server actions feature to PHP one of the
most offensive slurs you can make
against a JavaScript framework but the
biggest issue is that running nextjs is
fairly hard to do correctly outside of
verell and that's led to projects like
open next that take on the tedious job
of getting it to run anywhere next is
still the dominant meta framework but
nujs and the view ecosystem also had a
lot of cool updates in 2023 like its Dev
tools these tools run directly in the
browser and make it much easier to
understand the structure of a complex
application but one thing you may not
know about n is that many of its
components are available through the
unified JavaScript tools ecosystem like
if you don't care about VJs and just
want a web server you can use Nitro to
build a fast server with plain
JavaScript what's funny is I think the
VJs ecosystem has changed the least in
2023 and as a consequence it feels like
the most stable and predictable
ecosystem spelt on the other hand got
ruined in 2023 in a shocking
announcement a couple months ago spelt
announced a new feature called runes
that will dramatically change the
developer experience in version 5
instead of defining reactive variables
with Le there's now this thing called a
rune which is essentially a compiler
macro that tells the spelt compiler this
value is reactive spelt is also getting
rid of the Dollar Sign Co and syntax and
stores with runes like derived and
effect the initial response to these
changes were somewhat mixed with some
users feeling like these changes make
spelt look a lot more like react which
is the type of developer experience
they're trying to get away from but on
the other hand a lot of people love
these changes and see them as necessary
to evolve the framework in the right
direction as a hardcore user of spelt
myself I'm waiting for the final release
of version 5 before I form an opinion
the award for the most change framework
in 2023 though goes to angular it has a
long list of new features but the most
notable changes for angular haters out
there would be the new template syntax
which provides a cleaner way to handle
conditionals and Loops replacing things
like ngf and ng4 in addition angular has
also adopted signals much like all the
other Frameworks out there and brings a
new feature called defer views which
enables declarative lazy loading
directly in a template but most
importantly angular has a brand new logo
which was really the only thing holding
it back from being the world's most
popular framework in the past a lot of
crazy changes on the front end but on
the back end node.js has been quietly
getting better with node.js version 20
it released a new permissions model
which improves security by controlling
which features a script has access to
very much similar to what Dino released
a few years years ago and then with the
release of node 21 it introduced its own
websocket client which is based on the
websocket API in the browser the biggest
disruptor with backend JavaScript in
2023 though is bun it's a new JavaScript
runtime written in Zig that came out
with an awesome developer experience and
some wild claims about performance and
quite a few bugs were discovered after
the initial release but it still remains
a promising new way to do backend
JavaScript in the future and with that
we've looked at 10 different ways
JavaScript changed in 2023 but I almost
forgot the biggest one of all HTM X the
framework that showed that anyone can
capture the imagination of the
JavaScript ecosystem if you post
and meme hard enough on Twitter but most
importantly as I've shown here with
science hmx can actually eliminate a ton
of JavaScript compared to the status quo
approach taken by all the major
Frameworks it's the ideal JavaScript
framework for the JavaScript haters and
that's why today I'm thrilled and
honored to present the HDMX team with
the JavaScript framework of the Year
award which is basically the Nobel Prize
of JavaScript thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one